Most copywriting courses charge a grand
for the information that I'm about to
give you in this video for free. 41
copywriting secrets that I have
personally used to go from a nobody 5
years ago to a full-time six-figure
copywriter today with over 5,000 email
subscribers and over 11 million dollars
sold in the funnels that I've written
for myself and for my clients. This is
what I do all day long. Let's dive in.
Heads up, everything that I'm about to
show you in this video is in a cheat
sheet down below. Click the link, put
your email in, tell me where to send it,
and then you can use it anytime that you
want to write copy. All right, starting
with secret number one is your copy
should be a mirror. When people read
your copy, they should feel like they
are reading a story about themselves. It
should be emotionally resonant that when
they read it, they're nodding yes. Oh my
gosh, yes, this sounds exactly like yes,
this is the exact problem that I'm going
through. The copy is about them, not
you. Secret number two, people do not
care about you. Think of the term wifom,
what's in it for me. They care about
their problems, their pains, their
desires in life. They don't give two
rips about your success and what you've
done. Every sentence you write should be
for [music] them to solve their problem,
their life, move their things forward.
Secret number three is you have to find
your big behemoth idea. Great copy
actually doesn't start with writing, it
starts with a big idea, something so
explosive that when they see it, their
heart starts pounding. It matters that
much to them. It's so resonative to
what's happening in our culture, in
their life that they're saying, yes, I
need to know more about this now. Secret
number four is you need to make the
skeleton dance. Every product has
drawbacks. Don't hide those drawbacks,
show them to your reader. And what this
actually does is it creates
believability and trust in what you're
writing. People who only talk about the
good things of their product, people
start to assume they're hiding
something. Don't hide it, show it.
Secret number five is be a pastor.
Pastor stands for problem, agitation,
solution, testimonial, offer, response.
This is one of my most highly used,
highly converting frameworks. Talk about
the person's problem, agitate it,
meaning make it worse. If they don't
solve this, what happens? And then
introduce the solution, which is your
product. [music] Give testimonials,
proof, case studies, whatever it is to
prove that your solution works. Make
them an offer that they can't resist,
and then have them respond. Respond
right now to get this offer. Pastor,
secret number six is sell benefits, not
features. Steve Jobs is the most iconic
for this, where he sold a thousand songs
in your pocket with the iPod, instead of
saying [music]
5 GB of storage. No one cares about the
storage, they care about the songs in
their pocket. Another way to reframe
this is [music] when you sell a
quarter-inch drill bit, you're not
selling the drill bit, you're selling
the quarter-inch hole that someone gets
from the drill bit. What is the thing
that people, [music] your people, get
from buying your product? Not the
product itself. Secret number seven is
make your reader imagine themselves with
your product. Adobe is phenomenal at
this. They constantly show people using
Adobe Photoshop and a Adobe Lightroom,
and they're putting you in the
perspective of editing photos and making
these amazing designs. They're showing
your life with that product. What does
your reader's life look like after they
buy your product? Put them in that
image. Paint that picture. Secret number
eight is obey the 40-40-20 rule. 40% of
your success in sales comes from the
quality of the list, okay? The list of
people that you are selling to, whether
it's from meta ads, your email list,
whatever it is, your list of people. The
other 40% of your sales will be the
quality of the offer, and the last 20%
is [music] the copy, meaning great copy
cannot save you from a bad offer or bad
list. Fix those two things first. Make a
great offer to a great list, and the
copy will be more like fuel amplifier.
Secret number nine is people buy
emotionally, not logically. People will
justify logically, like if I go tell my
wife that I bought a thousand-dollar
course, I will tell her something like
it it on sale. That's a logical story
that I would tell my wife. But I didn't
buy it cuz it was on sale. I bought it
because I have a pain that the course
solves, or I'm greedy, or there's a fear
that is deep in my soul, and that course
promised me that it would solve that
fear for me. Those are the parts we
don't say out loud, but that's actually
why we buy. Secret number 10 is
deadlines are generous. They are not
pushy. What they're actually doing is
when you give a deadline, you are
forcing someone to make a decision to
buy or not buy. Whether they buy or not
buy, that's totally fine. Hopefully they
buy, but if they don't, that's okay.
They've made that decision, and so now
they have relief that's been stewing in
them, oh, should I buy this? Should I
not buy this? Well, now the decision is
made for you because the deadline is
over. Secret number 11 is long copy is
the daddy, okay? The more you say, the
more you sell. The more people read your
stories, your ideology, your features,
your benefits, everything about the
copy, the more you can get them to read,
the more they will be indoctrinated with
the idea of wanting to buy it from you.
You can't be boring. You have to be
exciting, but long copy will always
outpull short copy. Secret number 12 is
curiosity is the most potent drug in
humans. Humans are physically incapable
of not solving their curiosity. If you
say something that makes someone curious
about what you're going to say next,
they will want to click your headline,
or open your email, or read your sales
letter. So, in your copy, you need to
open a loop of curiosity. Say something
that they're already wondering, open the
loop there, and then tell the rest of
the story in the copy. Secret number 13
is AI cannot tell stories, but stories
sell. Everything you sell is bought by a
human, and humans are wired to process
information through stories. We have too
much information coming out of us, so we
tell ourselves a story. And the more
that your story feels real to them and
resonates with what they're going
through, the more likely they're going
to actually attach themselves to you and
your product, which then gets them to
read the whole sales letter. The more
they read, the more they sell, and so
on. Secret number 14 is great copy
cannot fix a bad [music] product. I
myself have gone through the rabbit hole
many of times where I've written great
copy for a really crappy product,
especially like in the e-com world when
I was taking clients on early, and I
learned my lesson. Before ever taking a
client, I started asking, "Hey, what
kind of testimonials, proof, case
studies, success stories do people like
what you have to sell?" If they don't
already like it, then I can't write for
it because copy is more like fuel. It
doesn't create sales, it amplifies
sales. If you don't have a fire already
going, there's nothing I can do for you.
But, if you have a fire going, I can
turn it into a roaring, exciting [music]
fire that sells with copy. Secret number
15 is write to a starving crowd. Find
people who are already interested and
desperate [music]
for what you have to offer. Stop trying
to create desire in something, "I think
people will like this." What do they
already like? What do they already want?
Why would they already want the thing
that you have? Gary Halbert told this
story when he was teaching a college
class, and he said, "If you could have
one advantage for opening a new burger
shop, what advantage would you like?"
And some people were like, "Oh, we want
the best prices." Or, "We want the best
location." Or, "We want the best
ingredients." And Halbert was like,
"Nope, you're all wrong because what I'm
going to choose as an advantage is I'm
going to want a hungry crowd. Who cares
if you have the best prices, the best
ingredients, or the best location? If
you don't have a hungry, starving crowd
who want what you have, then you will
not sell jack." Secret number 16, study
one master. I've been studying
copywriting for 5 years, and my first
year I bumbled around trying to study a
bunch of different gurus. Don't do that.
Find one person whose copywriting you
absolutely are addicted to. Study
everything they write, everything they
sell. Buy all of their courses. Buy
everything you can get your hands on.
Turn them into your mentor from a
distance. And once you have read
everything that person has to offer,
then move on and start studying someone
else. It's way too confusing and hard to
learn copywriting if all you do is
bounce from mentor to guru to guru to
guru because everybody's angle is a
little bit different [music] and it's
confusing to you. Secret number 17 is
proof smokes promises for breakfast.
Promises are like balloons. The bigger
they are, the more likely they pop.
Anybody can make a promise. Anybody can
make a claim and it doesn't make it
believable and it doesn't make it
trustworthy. But the rarest ingredient
to high selling copy is proof. Proof
through testimonials, case studies,
demonstration, anything like that that
makes people believe, "Oh, this actually
works." So, put proof in your headline.
Put proof in your body copy. Put proof
in your offer. Put proof after your
objections. Put proof everywhere you can
to show people that this is legit.
Secret number 18 is demonstration, maybe
the greatest form of proof. P.T. Barnum,
one of the greatest showmen in the
world, helped Otis elevators get off the
map and now become 70% of the elevators
on the planet Earth. And the way that
they did that was through dramatic
demonstration. He put the guy, Otis, who
made the actual elevator, he put him
floating in the middle of a town square
and the elevator that he made would
actually stop him from dying if the if
the ropes were cut off on the elevator.
He did that live. He cut the ropes live.
The elevator flew and then it stopped
based on the mechanism that he made.
This was a dramatic demonstration to
prove that his elevators were better
than everyone else's elevators. After
that, he became a multi-billionaire in
like the 1800s, all because of that one
demonstration. Can you demonstrate your
product? It will sell more. Secret
number 19 is pain sells more than
desire. Promising someone all this good
fluffy, bright, and future [music]
things is good, but it doesn't sell as
much as finding a pain that they have
right now and showing them how to solve
it. People are less attached to the
future. They are so indrenched in what
they're going through right now that
they will buy whatever it takes to get
out of discomfort. Secret number 20 is
write in your own market's words. Very
much like secret number one where you're
mirroring your market, the way that you
do that is you scroll through forums and
comments, direct messages, you actually
go hang out with the people in your
market that you're trying to sell to.
What are the words that they're saying?
Use those exact words and put them into
your copy. Very much like the John
Carlton one-legged golfer. He was
actually talking to the guy who created
the one-legged golfer method and that
guy was the one who gave him the
headline idea for that sales letter that
made millions of dollars. John didn't
write that sales letter, he stole it
from his market. Secret 21, think like a
fish. Don't hang out with fishermen,
other marketers who are really obsessed
with like fancy lures and things like
that. That's how fishermen think.
They're buying courses and they're
listening to the latest gurus. Spend
time swimming with your market. What do
they care about? What do they act? Where
do they spend their money? Where do they
go? What do they buy? You have to
understand the people that you're
selling to way more than the people that
are trying to sell to them. Secret
number 22, know their awareness level.
Eugene Schwartz created the five stages
of awareness. Unaware [music] to problem
aware, solution aware, product aware,
offer aware. If I'm selling something
totally brand new and people don't even
understand that they have [music] this
problem. Let's say I'm selling some sort
of brand new AI service. People may be
problem aware. They don't even know that
this problem occurs, let alone solution
[music] aware. The way that I would sell
that is completely differently. I may be
telling stories, I may be overcoming
objection. Whereas opposed to if I'm
selling a brand new phone, everybody
knows about phones. Smartphones have
taken over the market since 2007. And so
instead of selling with stories and
things like that, what I'm actually
going to do is sell with an unbelievable
offer because they're solution aware,
product aware and offer aware. So I have
to make an offer that's so different, so
unique from everyone else that that's
how I stand out in that saturated
market. Secret number 23, play golf
[music] often. I usually play golf once
to twice a week. Whenever I'm stuck
writing copy or I can't think of a new
breakthrough idea, I actually leave
everything that I'm doing and I go play
golf for 3-4 hours. By the time I come
back, I am brewing with fresh angles and
ideas because I'm letting my mind do the
work [music] to find the answers for me.
This is called incubation from Joe
Sugarman. It is vastly underrated. Most
hustle bros just try and work through
slumps. Never do that. It is way more
fun to go play 4 hours of golf and come
back with flowing ideas. Secret number
24, write like a barista. Pretend that
you are barista at a coffee shop. You're
pulling a shot sitting at the coffee bar
and you are having a conversation with
them and you are excited [music]
about the thing that you are telling
them about, the product you are trying
to sell them. You're genuinely excited
and you're having a conversation and
you're talking to them as if they were
talking back to you. This is how you
write copy. It's super simple, easy to
understand, short sentences, clear
words, no fancy corporate jargon that
nobody gets. In fact, one of my hacks
for this is a lot of the times I'll
actually take my phone and I'll voice
dictate my ideas stories into my phone
to get my natural verbage flow and then
I'll go back and edit it cleanly on the
computer. That writes probably half my
copy. Secret number 25, sell identity
not products. Don't sell someone running
shoes, sell someone on the idea of being
a runner. People buy who they want to
become. And if you can attach your
product to their identity, they will be
far more attracted to the thing you're
trying to sell them. Secret number 26,
every sentence has to earn the next.
Meaning if the sentence I just read
doesn't make me want to read the next
sentence, you need to cut it. Because
getting people to read a lot of copy is
like taming a lion. You have to be very
careful with the way you walk that lion
down your sales page because one slip up
and that lion is going to get scared and
run away. Secret number 27, compete with
Netflix. You are not competing with
other advertisements. You are competing
with other entertainment, TikTok,
Netflix, YouTube. And so, everything you
write has to be so compelling, so
addictive, so entertaining that they
don't want to attract those other forms
of entertainment. They want to sit and
read exactly what [music] you have to
say. Secret number 28, one, write your
copy for one person with one offer to
one funnel that solves one problem and
has one big idea. Anytime you try and
layer multiple offers or multiple
stories or it could sell this person,
but it could also sell this person, it's
noise, irrelevant. You might as well
have never written it, waste of time.
Secret number 29, your headline has one
job to get them to read the next
sentence. You're not selling the
product, you are getting them to invest
in reading the rest of what you have to
say. That is it. Capture their
attention, open the loop of curiosity,
and get them in. Secret number 30, be
willing to repel the losers. There are
people who your product is not for. You
should call those people out and tell
them exactly why they should not buy
your product because one, you don't want
them to buy your product. And two, by
calling out who it is not for, you
actually increase the desire from the
people who it is for. It feels more
exclusive like, oh yeah, I'm not that
guy. I'm definitely not that person. Oh,
this must be for me. So, while you're
repelling the losers, you are increasing
the desire for someone who is willing to
buy
>> [music]
>> to actually pull the trigger. Secret
number 31, people buy you before they
buy your product. Whether you are a
personal brand or a company, your voice,
your personality, and your personal
views on life will actually encourage
someone to listen more from you because
people like us buy from us. It's one of
the reasons I've bought so much stuff
from people like Daniel Throssell and
Ben Settle because I am very much like
those guys. A lot of Ben's world views I
have. And Daniel, we're both 33 and we
are dads and we have kids, very
disciplined, we believe in Jesus. So, we
have all these things in common which
makes me more attracted to those two
guys and what they're selling because
they're like me. Secret number 32,
people read with their eyes. Formatting
matters. Short sentences, paragraph
breaks, rhythms, one sentence to three
sentences to two sentences, big bold
text to actually break up the
paragraphs. Your formatting actually
reduces the illusion of all the copy
that they have to read and it creates
this slippery slope where they kind of
just glide down because you make it so
easy for them to digest. It's like a
meal on the plate. If it looks ugly and
gross and overwhelming, you're going to
have a harder time eating it. Secret
number 33, inject a give a attitude
into all of your copy. Neediness is the
ultimate way of repelling great buyers
from you. If they read your copy and
feel like you're begging for the sale,
it's gross. People don't like that. It's
it's unattractive to us. Gary Halbert
used to do this thing where after he
made an offer, he'd say, "Look, you can
buy this or not. Either way, I'm eating
steak tonight." Which basically was
saying like, "Dude, I don't care whether
you buy or not. I'm rich, I'm good, I'm
happy, I have a great life. I'm eating
all this good stuff. I'm going to be
having dinner with my friends and
family. You can do whatever you want."
The ultimate aura of non-neediness.
Inject that into your copy. Secret
number 34, make your copy itself
valuable. You are now 10-15 minutes into
this video and little did you know that
this actually [music] is a sales letter
to get you to download my cheat sheet,
to join my email list, to read my email
list, and to buy my stuff. But you're
still watching because this is one of
the most valuable videos on the
internet. And so it's addictive and
you're falling down the rabbit hole.
That is okay. When you can make your ad
itself so valuable, it actually doesn't
feel like an ad, it feels it feels like
pure value and so people don't throw
that away, they don't skip that. They
keep the things that are actually
helpful to them. Secret number 35,
specificity is credibility. Don't say
things like, "I'll help you lose
weight." Say something like, "I'll help
you lose 10 lb in 30 days." Specific
claims actually feel true where vague
claims feel fake. Secret number 36, do
not reinvent the wheel. You can go to
websites like swipe.co or create your
own swipe file of emails and ads that
have worked on you in the past and
figure out why do they work? What do I
like? What do I not like?
>> [music]
>> And use that to recreate the wheel for
your own emails, your own sales pages,
your own ads. Figure out what's winning
and then take notes, swipe those, make
them your own, but please don't steal
someone's work. Secret number 37 is say
the quiet part out loud. You have things
in you that are polarizing, contrasting,
and creates massive conflict in people's
lives. You need to be polarizing. You
need to say things that will shock
people because shock creates conflict,
conflict creates attention, attention
creates traffic, and traffic creates
sales. Secret number 38, what to say
beats how to say it. Every market has a
trigger based on what's happening in
their world, in the culture, in the
zeitgeist, in their industry that is top
of mind and it's all that they're
thinking about. And if you can figure
out their biggest pain, biggest fear,
biggest desire that's happening
culturally right now and say something
about that, you will trigger them to
then give you their attention. Secret
number 39 is stack value before
revealing price. What you actually want
to do is you want [music] to pump up
your product so highly, so many offers,
bonuses, [music] premiums, benefits,
jam-packed before you ever say the price
that the person is nodding along and
they're thinking, "Oh my gosh, this is
going to be a thousand dollars. [music]
This is going to be two thousand
dollars. This is going to be incredibly
expensive. But they're too curious now
and by the time they make it to the
page, they're immensely relieved when
they see, "Oh, it's three hundred
dollars. I thought it was going to be a
thousand dollars." So you actually price
anchor them with value first. This makes
it way more likely that they're actually
going to buy when your actual price is
so much lower than their internal anchor
price. Secret number 40, consumption is
good, but absorption is great. Reading
and understanding are two very different
things. You need to be able to say
things, your stories, your copy, your
offers, so clearly, so simply, that they
not only read the whole thing, but they
actually understand [music] it, they
absorb it. They're able to make a
decision because they know exactly what
they're going to get, when they're going
to get it, how they're going to get it,
and what it's going to do for them. And
lastly, secret number 41, ruthlessly
attack your enemies. [music] If there
was someone out there trying to sell
your people an inferior product, or
worse, a product that is actually
harmful to them, you need to attack
them. It creates conflict. You need to
say why this product is trash. You have
a responsibility to tell your people why
this will hurt them. And two, it
actually creates this intense conflict
between you and them that is incredibly
dramatic, which creates attention, which
creates traffic, which creates sales.
That is all 41 secrets that I have used
in the last 5 years to help me become a
full-time six-figure copywriter, and I
believe they're going to be immensely
helpful for you. What I want you to do
next is one, click the link in the
description below to get this cheat
sheet. You can print it, you can keep it
on your desktop, you can keep it
wherever. So, anytime you need to write
copy, browse through it, get some ideas,
and make sure that your copy rips.
Secondly, if you're new to the channel,
please consider subscribing. It tells me
that you want to see more videos and
content like this. And everyone else,
please like, comment, let me know how
you thought about this one, and what you
want me to do next. I appreciate you
guys. Thank you so much for allowing me
the opportunity to help you, to serve
you. Enjoy it, grab it, and until next
time, I'll catch you.